- I think a lot of people believe
that if they try something
that doesn't work.
That's it. How many people do we all know
that have some sort of hobby?
Some of them are working
these jobs they really,
really hate, and they're coming home
and they're going to their
workshop or their garage
or their kitchen, and they're tinkering
and they're building and
they're making stuff.
And how many of those people,
if they had the audacity
or took, had a little nudge
or a little push, would
actually say, you know what?
That's my life's work.
That's what I want to do.
I want to spend my time doing that stuff
and sharing my gift with the world.
I think what's holding back an explosion
of entrepreneur
entrepreneurship is we as a,
as a society generally
don't embrace failure
the way we probably should.
And that, I think is how you build really
large, impactful companies.
- Well believe nation. Welcome back.
I have a very special guest with me today.
Harley, who is the president of Shopify,
also has a new company called Fire Belly.
Tea. Welcome aboard, man.
- Thanks for having me.
This is very exciting.
I I love your hoodie,
by the way. Very cool.
- Brandon, we got the
airplane. This is, I love it.
This, for me, this is actually related.
So like entrepreneurship to me is
where we're the paper airplane kind
of taking off into the wind.
We're not, we're not the jet
plane with all the resources
and we kind of hit the, the
wind and the turbulence,
but we still are trying to
get to a different place.
- It also is, is just, just to sort
of beat up the metaphor a little bit more.
It also, what's, what's interesting about
that particular metaphor, I think is
that the paper airplane,
you know, the cost
of failure is not that big.
And then as you get larger
and larger, the cost of
failure sort of goes up.
But it sort of insinuates
that in the early days
of building a business, that's
the time you to take chances
to pivot, to try new things.
Because again, if you
lose one paper airplane,
you just grab another piece of paper.
Whereas when you get in
sort of the jet territory,
that becomes a lot more challenging.
- There you go. I like that man.
I might, I might, I might
borrow that. Take it, steal it.
- It's all yours.
- So expending, expand the analogy.
I love that. Entrepreneurs,
man. Why do you care so much?
- Oh, I mean, where do I start?
I'll, maybe I start the personal side.
I mean, entrepreneurship is
sort of just baked into the,
into my DNA to DNA, my
family, my, you know,
we are a family of immigrants.
We came to Canada in 56
from Hungary Post, you know,
Holocaust survivors made
their way to Hungary.
Hungarian revolution
happens not a very good time
to be in Hungary, Canada,
fortunately let in 40,000
Hungarian immigrants at the time.
My family moves here and they don't know,
they don't know the
language, they don't speak,
they don't speak the language,
they don't have any money,
they have no real transferrable skills.
But they were able to start selling in
my family's case, eggs.
And maybe they set up a little
stall at a farmer's market in
Montreal and started selling eggs.
So in many ways, I mean,
you know, my grandfather
who sold those eggs, didn't
call himself an entrepreneur,
but entrepreneurship was
the tool that he used to,
to provide for the family,
to put food over on the table
and put a roof over their head.
And then fast forward, like, I dunno, 50
or 60 years later, in the early
nineties, I'm, I don't know,
13 years old, I want to be a dj.
No one would hire me.
'cause I didn't know how
to dj, why would they hire me?
I started a little DJ
company and hired myself and,
and was able to, you
know, DJ like 500 parties.
When I'm, now I'm 17, I'm, I
was living in south Florida
with my family, moved back
to Montreal to go to McGill.
Family loses all our
money once again, pull out
that tool called entrepreneurship
and start selling t-shirts.
And, and, you know, lo
and behold was, was able to, to pay
for tuition help my mom and sisters.
My dad wasn't around at that point.
So entrepreneurship on a very
personal level has always
been, I believe the, the
greatest tool in my life,
in my family's life to, to solve problems.
And then when you sort of
expand it beyond just me on a,
on a personal level, but,
but looking more sort of,
you know, on a, on a global level,
entrepreneurship has been
this incredible thing that we
as humans have, have,
have used to create value,
to solve problems, to
find our life's work,
to create our own versions of success.
Whether, whether that's, you
know, sending our, our daughter
to ballet lessons or it's,
you know, building 40
or $50 billion company.
So in many ways the Venn
diagram of my personal interest
and my professional interests,
I'm really fortunate
'cause they very much overlap.
And, and, and the that
overlap is entrepreneurship.
And, and today, as we sit here
and, and talk Evan, every 30
or so seconds, a brand new
entrepreneur gets their very
first sale on Shopify.
And I've devoted my entire life
and we'll devote my life
to helping create more
of those for sales.
- I love it, man. And I'm,
I'm based in Toronto, Canada.
So it's, you've been such a
huge success story for us.
Oh, thank you. But also just the entire
entrepreneur community.
Talk about the decision to
now share a message, right?
So you're not just the
kind of president, CEO
behind the scenes making things happen,
but you're making content,
you're posts on Instagram,
you're coming on shows.
What's, what's the goal with all of that?
- In my world, and I, I think your world,
and I think a lot of your listeners and,
and the people that watch your,
your incredible show, Evan,
I think most of us are sort
of steeped in this idea
that entrepreneurship
is something we can do.
If you go to, you know,
meetups or startup events
or tech conferences or you know,
you're on Reddit or Twitter
or Instagram, there's a lot
out there that is shop that is,
that is sort of entrepreneurship related.
But I think sometimes we
forget that the vast majority
of the world entrepreneurship
is not perceived
as something that is accessible.
Most people perceive it
as either too expensive
or too complicated or too difficult.
It is not something that
is as this is prominent
or features as prominently in most places.
Like it does in, you
know, in the case of you
and I like the Canadian technology
or the Canadian startup world,
every, you know, I dunno
how many friends you have
that are entrepreneurs.
I have tons. My my dad's an entrepreneur.
My grandfather's an entrepreneur.
My best friends are entrepreneurs.
My wife's an entrepreneur.
My, you know, my kids are are,
you know, setting up little,
little lemonades lemonade
stands inside our house, right?
Yeah. In Ottawa here and selling lemonade
and trying to figure out
and trying to teach 'em.
But, you know, cost of
goods sold and, and,
and how they think about profitability
and how they think about marketing
and, and sales and all that.
But that is not the case
in most places. Most.
And and you see this simply
by the amount of people
that you know, that go to university.
Not because they want an education, but
because they want that piece of paper
to then go and get a job with it.
And so part of what I think
my life's work is beyond just,
you know, helping to build
this, this wonderful, I,
I think the greatest engine
for entrepreneurship is
Shopify, unequivocally.
I don't say that 'cause of
the president of Shopify.
I say that because before I
worked at Shopify, you know,
15 years ago I was a merchant on Shopify.
I sold t-shirts on Shopify as one
of the first merchants
when I was in law school.
But the vast majority of people
do not believe it's, it's accessible.
So I think that I, I'm uniquely positioned
and have a unique responsibility
to share those stories,
those anecdotes,
and try to get more people to
think about entrepreneurship.
Think, think about this just as a
mental model just for a second.
How many people do we all know
that have some sort of hobby,
they make, you know, beautiful ceramics
or they, you know,
build beautiful figurines
like I have back here,
or they make incredible,
you know, I don't know,
chicken soup like my mom
does, but matza ball soup.
And not all of them, not
all those people should
commercialize those hobbies to become
entrepreneurs, but some of them should.
Some of them are working these
jobs they really, really hate.
And then they're coming
home at five o'clock or
whenever they come home and
they're going to their workshop
or their garage or their
kitchen and they're tinkering
and they're building and
they're making stuff.
And how many of those people,
if they had the audacity
or took, had a little nudge
or a little push, would actually say,
you know what, that's my life's work.
That's what I want to do. I
want to spend my time doing
that stuff and sharing
my gift with the world.
That nudge, that push.
I, I take that very seriously
and I believe that I might be able
to encourage more people
to try their hand at it.
And therefore they may find
their own unique versions
of success and they may
find their life's work.
And if I can be valuable in that way
and I can share, share some of
that with the world, that's,
that's a, that's what I should be doing.
- I love that. You know, you,
you're getting your kids
starting lemonade sands is
how I started, I think
how a lot of us started.
But you're teaching
your daughter about cost
of goods sold. She's making her
- Lemonade.
Well, I mean we're, you know,
at this point, you know,
le there, there's, we're
living in an inflationary
environment right now and, and
lemons are getting more expensive.
So she needs to know we
have to charge more money
for lemonade and she should
understand why we should
charge more people for lemonade.
- I love it. No, that's great. You've kind
of eliminated the barriers
to get started in selling products, right?
A lot of entrepreneurs, technology
is not their main thing.
And so cool, you don't
have to be the expert,
just open up a Shopify
account and, and you're up and running.
How important is community to it?
'cause, 'cause you mentioned you've got,
you've got all your friends and family
and your wife, you
know, our entrepreneurs.
What is Shopify doing around
the community side of things
and, and, and maybe where are
you going with community so
that entrepreneurs can
be connected together?
- Yeah, I think about community
in two sort of buckets.
The first bucket is just
the economy of scale.
So we don't really talk
about this very often,
but if you were to pretend
that Shopify was a single
retailer just for a second one single,
if you combine every one of
our stores, we have millions
of stores, but pretend
they were one store,
that one store would be the second largest
online store in America.
That's crazy after Amazon and
well above, you know, target
or Best Buy walmart.com or
any, any of those others.
So that means that you, as
a Shopify merchant today,
you are able to build a
unique independent business
that is yours, your brand,
your business, you own it.
But at the same time, you
can leverage these economies
of scale on things like
payments or shipping or capital
or technology or, or, or
infrastructure for that matter.
Anything for that matter.
So that's part of the com.
Like by being part of
the Shopify ecosystem
or community, you immediately,
even though you yourself
may be a small business,
you are now able to leverage
the much larger benefits
of being part of, of, of
this, this, of this community.
And that allows you to compete
better, that allows you,
you know, entrepreneurship
is still difficult.
Most, most small businesses fail.
But what we're trying to
do is simply try to change
that direction just as,
as, as much as we can,
which is still, you know, not that much
because again, it's
entrepreneurship is hard,
but we think we can make your likelihood
to success a little bit easier.
And again, if you're reselling
someone else's products
or you're a drop shipper
or you are a creator
and you're, you don't, you're
not making very many things.
You know, that additional 20
basis points or 10 basis points
or 40 basis points on credit
card processing rates,
that makes a big difference.
Yeah. Or your ability to get
shipping labels from, you know,
any of the big shipping
companies at the same rate,
at the same price that 10 years ago,
the biggest companies on
the planet were getting
that makes a difference too.
So that's part of the
sort of community side.
The other part of the
community side is just
entrepreneurship can be a lonely endeavor.
It's not, you know, you, you
tend to do it by yourself.
And so one of the things we try to foster
through things like, for
example, Shopify Spaces,
which we have in, we have one in New York,
we have one in Los Angeles
where any entrepreneur can just
drop in or the Shopify forums
or any of the Shopify, you
know, online communities,
whether it's on Facebook or it's on,
you know, Twitter, Instagram.
We try to facilitate more of
that community feel even though everyone's
running their own independent business.
And I think the cool part about
running a business in 2022
relative to, you know, 1922
or 1822 for that matter, is
there was a sense in, in, in
previous generations of entrepreneurs
that things were zero sum.
Meaning if you made
more, someone made less.
And that often was
because if you were in
a physical, you know,
let's say you were in a town
square a hundred years ago
and there was a baker there
and you open up a bakery,
there's the total adjustable
market of that, of that for
that bakery is, is is pretty clear.
It's the people that live there that
want to buy bread who can afford bread.
So if you open a, a bakery
and there's another
bakery than the street,
you may make more money and
that other baker makes less money.
But that's not the way
modern business works.
Modern business is fundamentally
positive sum meaning
you may find a niche or a
geography or a demographic
or a community that, that
that other baker never even encountered
because it wasn't obvious.
So maybe your bakery in the,
on the internet, which has,
you know, effectively
a total pop, you know,
total addressable market of anyone
with an internet connection
and a credit card.
Maybe you, the other bakery does well,
but you make, you know,
your bakery ha is, you know,
you have cookies in
the shapes of dinosaurs
or something my kids are really into right
now for some reason.
So that baker's making cookies,
but you're making like dinosaur cookies
and like people that
want dinosaur cookies on
the, on the internet.
If you combine everyone that wants it,
that's actually a real, you
know, that's a real audience.
So we try to facilitate
community, not just
because we think it's
important from a competitive
advantage for these entrepreneurs.
You know, you combine a bunch of tiny
little lights, you get the sun.
That's important from an
economy to scale perspective,
but also because entrepreneurship
is difficult and lonely.
And if we want to be the entrepreneurship
company, we very much do.
I think we have the best
shot at being that globally.
We also have to facilitate those types
of connections and relationships.
- What I love is if if somebody
is, you know, watching this
and they're the only entrepreneur family
and they've got this crazy
day to start a business
and nobody else believes in
them and they set up on Shopify
and they see somebody else
who made their first 10 K
on Shopify or a hundred k
or a million on Shopify, it's like, huh,
they made a million
dollars selling dinosaur
cookies. Like maybe I can
- It change, it changes everything.
I mean, you know, a lot
of what I talk about,
whether it's on social media
or it's on earnings calls,
is I talk about about Shopify
of course, but I i I
really try to focus on
the Ben Francis Jim Shark story
or the Richard Fashion
Nova story, or the Tim
and Joey All story, or the
Trina and Heather fig story.
I try to focus on these stories of,
or David Bombas of these
stories of people that started
at their mom's kitchen table with an idea
and a concept and a product.
And in many cases are now, you know,
publicly traded multi-billion
dollar companies
and they are owning their, their industry.
I mean, they're like, I
don't know this for sure,
but I suspect they're at some
board meeting inside of Nike.
Someone brought up the challenger
and the risk of gym shark.
That's an unbelievable
thing that, you know,
a college dropout from
London who's selling pizza
or delivering pizza, I should say is now,
is now being considered
to be a real insurgent
relative to the incumbent of Nike.
That's, that's an amazing thing.
And those, so those are
stories I want ex I want
to tell more of because again,
I'm not saying everyone's
going to build their own
gyms shark, but not everyone has to.
Ben Francis really wanted to build
a very large scale apparel company.
He wanted to change an industry.
He felt that there was no
gr no great clothing for
that particular niche.
So not people that go
necessarily go to the gym
that are bodybuilders and not people doing
yoga, there's something in the middle.
And he felt that that
market was underserved
and so he wanted to solve
that underserved problem.
But, you know, Mike d from
Durham, North Carolina,
who's a friend of mine who
makes Mike D's barbecue sauce,
he doesn't necessarily want to
build a a billion dollar brand.
He loves making barbecue sauce
and sharing barbecue
sauce with his community
and the people that he loves.
And he wants it to, you know,
allow him and his, his wife
and his two daughters
to have a great life.
And by the way, Mikey's
barbecue sauce is fantastic.
It's just shout up to that brand.
But his definition
of success is fundamentally
different than than
Francis a gym shark is. And that's okay.
- How do you calibrate the impact?
This is something I struggle
with personally, right?
We've had almost half a billion
people watch the videos.
I, I don't know what that
number means to, feels hard
to connect to all of your stores combined.
It's the second largest retailer.
It, it's just how do
you calibrate the impact
that you're actually having on the world?
- The second largest retailer
in aggregate is a cool one.
The other one that i I love
is, you know, I mean that,
that every 30 seconds or so a
new entrepreneur gets their first sale.
That's a big one too,
but one way to do it's,
I think the best companies
create opportunities
for others instead of
just conquering them.
And so for Shopify, that
means for every dollar,
this is a real stat for
every dollar in revving
that Shopify made last year in
2021, our merchants made $38.
So what we're trying to do is
like, we've been lowering the,
the barriers to entry
into entrepreneurship for,
I think actually today's our 16th birthday
Shopify's 16th birthday,
which is kind of cool.
So we've been, we've been lowering these
barriers for, for 16 years.
And then if you even go beyond
just just our merchants,
you look at our partner
ecosystem, our partner ecosystem
supported something like 650,000 jobs
and generated $32 billion
in revenue in 2021.
That's up like 45% since the prior year.
So, you know, they, I
think there's that term,
the Bill Gates line in terms
of, you know, you, you know,
you have an ecosystem or real
ecosystem when you create more
value for others and
you capture for ourself
or when you capture for yourself,
Shopify has that, we have
that in spades and we look at
that from a partner perspective,
but also from a merchant perspective.
And then you also kind of
think about from an impact,
can we try to not just
grow our piece of the pie?
So if the pie is the amount
of entrepreneurs in the world,
we can grow our piece of the pie
by ensuring more entrepreneurs.
You Shopify, I mean we should do that.
We, we've been doing that, but
what if we actually grow the pie itself?
What if we convince more people
to try their hand in entrepreneurship
that wouldn't otherwise do so?
And that I think is how
you build really large,
impactful companies and real businesses,
not necessarily just by taking
a bigger piece of the pie,
but by growing the pie itself.
- How do you bring that
momentum or sense of urgency
or sense of impact that you're having
to then the people on the team?
Like if somebody is working
kind of back in engineering,
working on the next feature
is like layers removed from
the customers and the stories.
How do you as a leader
ensure everybody feels like
what they're doing every
day actually matters?
- You don't remove them.
You make sure that every
single person at Shopify spends
time talking to merchants, which they do.
You make sure that as part
of the onboarding joining
Shopify, you build a store,
you use the product, you
ensure that it's part of onboarding.
And as part of, you know,
your tenure at Shopify,
you jump on the phones and
take support calls, you ensure
that people at Shopify, you know, speak
to entrepreneurs in their community.
I mean, when Covid hit,
we encouraged everyone at the company.
I think at the time we were, I
dunno, close to 10,000 people
to go out to their
communities and figure
out how we can help.
And so, you know, I think like a week
or two post covid hitting like
May, 2020, we had a hack days
and you saw people creating,
you know, a gift card product
so that you know, their
service-based business in their
community can start selling on
Shopify and make some money.
You saw people creating, you
know, grocery functionality.
So if you can with the
grocery store, consumers can,
or a small grocery store can start selling
to the ETN consumer.
You don't create this separation between
frontline and back office.
Rather you make everyone
deeply aware of the mission.
The second thing you do is,
and this is not, I don't think
anything that's going to be,
you know, overly provocative or,
or interesting, but it's, it's the truth.
The vast majority
of people at Shopify
self-identify as entrepreneurs.
And you mentioned, you know, fire Belly,
the reason I started Fire Belly, I mean,
I love tea, I love starting new things.
I don't have exactly all
the time in the world
to do these things, but it felt to me that
the last online business
that I started was in 2006.
And I felt that I wanted to
really understand in a very deep
and with real empathy,
not, not like I, I know
what it's like to be an
entrepreneur, like understand
what it's like right now
to be an entrepreneur.
And the best way I could have done that,
which makes me think better
at my role as the president
of Shopify is to start
a brand new business.
And so that's why we launched
Fire Belly Tea in in November.
And that, and, and that's
not that interesting
or that's not that unique.
It's not like it wasn't a big deal
that I launched Fire Belly
because so many people
at Shopify have their own
online stores as well.
Bush PO's a really good example of that.
David Gaylord built that.
She, he, he was on the
support team at Shopify
and it's like, it's a real
big business now, you know,
Beth Orian, there's like,
there's so many of these T TST
by Sheena Brady, there's all
these incredible entrepreneurs
at Shopify who work at Shopify
who also have great businesses.
That's how you ensure
that you don't just talk about mission,
but the mission is actually
embedded into the culture
of the company and the
people that work there.
- Yeah, I'm fine that I'm
struggling to do it effectively
with my team and we have
40 people, so, you know,
it's inspiring to see
you doing it at a much,
much larger scale than
- Me.
It's, it's not easy, right?
I mean, most people I think
misunderstand cultures
being, you know, the hoodies
or the logos or the signs
you put up on the one.
It's not what culture is.
Culture is what people do
when no one is watching,
when no one is looking and
you're free to do whatever you want.
What do you do? How do you
act? How do you do your work?
And I think, you know, there's a lot
of great companies to work at.
I think if you come to work
at Shopify, you're coming
because you truly believe
in this mission that a world
with more entrepreneurs is better
because you deeply believe
that more small businesses
should have access to the tools
that mostly the big companies
have had, have had access
to historically.
And if you believe that it's
easy to it to live that,
that mission, it's, it's not
like, you know, it, it, it,
it's not difficult.
We're not selling sugar water,
we're not selling advertising.
We are selling for most
people their ability
to find their own versions of success
and to find their life's
work that matters.
- I love the Steve Jobs call out there.
I talked a lot of presidents
and what I love about you is
you're not just talking about
like the macroeconomic trends
and talking to the media of,
you know, perfect president,
but like you actually
deeply care about the thing
that you're making and still
deeply rooted in helping your
customers, which is
refreshing and awesome.
And, and I want more when
when's the Harley podcast coming
out and like book tour and I like, I,
- Yeah, that's where IIII don't,
don't expect that anytime soon.
I, you know, it is difficult
to run a very large
publicly traded, you know,
multinational company.
It takes up a lot of time
and you have to build real
scaffolding and have a really
strong team around you.
So, you know, if I felt
that I could create more value for Shopify
and create more value for
entrepreneurs, I would probably
do one of those things.
But I think the best thing
that I can do for, for,
for entrepreneurs and for small businesses
around the world is to
continue to, you know, do my,
do my best work at Shopify.
- What do you think is
missing for entrepreneurs?
And you've solved a lot
of the technical problems
of people getting up and,
and being able to sell so they
can focus on what they love.
What, what else is missing
to help a entrepreneur launch
their business and be successful?
- I think a lot of
people believe that they,
if they try something that
doesn't work, that's it.
They, it just didn't
work. This is our fault.
This is my fault. And also,
you know, Evan, your fault
because we we're, you and I
are entrepreneur storytellers.
We believe that we are, you know, we, we,
we basically, that's what we do.
We're, we are storytellers
and we tell the stories
of great businesses
and great entrepreneurs
and great, you know,
founders and innovators,
but we all, we often forget to
talk about the, the failures.
And I think the reason
that's dangerous, and,
and you know, you
and I should be hyper
aware of this, is that by
neglecting telling the
full story, you know,
some great entrepreneur
comes on your, your show
and talks about their big success.
And by not telling all the
failure, the failed attempts,
we make it seem as if if you try something
and it doesn't work, that's the end of it.
Which, which is not the case.
I think that, you know,
talking about resiliency
or perseverance is, is is
not anything new in, in,
in a conversation like this.
But what I think most people
miss about entrepreneurship is
that it's usually the
second or third business
that really hits a home
run or, or, or the second
or third attempt before you
actually hit the home run.
That for many of us
and many people right
now that are starting,
it will not be the thing
they're working on right now.
If you look at our most
successful stores on Shopify,
and you look at their admin,
you look at their account
history, you'll see that many
of them have started
like two or three stores
before settling on that,
on that final store
that actually worked, that is not well
articulated in our, in our industry.
And I think we should
do a better job of that.
And, and I, I am, I I I should
- That would be a pretty cool
stat, you know, if you had it,
you know, for anybody who's
now crossed over seven figures
in their store, how many
other stores did they have
before they hit seven figures?
- Yeah, yeah. I, I, I don't
know, I don't know that stat,
but that, that would be interesting.
You know, I, I I think
also where you're going
with your questions, what else is missing?
You know, manufacturing is difficult.
We don't help with manufacturing really.
I mean, it's not just, it's just not part
of the shop by product offering.
And I, I don't think it will be, but,
but that's difficult, right?
That that is difficult.
It was difficult before.
It's difficult now, but
there are other things
that were difficult that got much easier.
You know, for example, finding your
first customer, finding an audience.
When I was selling T-shirts
back in 2006 on Shopify,
the only way for me to
get an audience to come
to my online story, it was called Smer.
The only way for me to get an audience was
to spend money on AdWords.
Facebook ads didn't exist then.
Facebook didn't really exist that much.
I think they were just sort
of, you know, they were,
it was sort of the first
iteration of Facebook,
so it was Google ads,
therefore, the person that
had the most amount of money,
the most amount of
capital ended up winning.
It was very simple, simple equation.
Put a dollar in here, get a
dollar 10 out the other side.
I didn't have a lot of dollars,
therefore I didn't have a
lot of dollar tens on the other side.
So there was inherently
this bias towards those
with capital made more money.
I don't think that's the case
anymore. I think in 2022,
you know, resourcefulness
is more important than
resource and resources.
And, you know, capital's, you know,
re creativity is more
important than capital.
Some of the best business
on shop that are doing tens
of millions or a hundred millions
or a billion dollar a year
on or, or more on the, on the
platform, they started simply
by, you know, a Reddit
form or a Facebook group
or, you know,
engaging on a particular
hashtag on Instagram or Twitter.
And they're like, Hey,
I guess you're in my
community now, by the way.
Like, let me add somebody
to the community,
and then eventually I'm going to
also like, have a product.
Would you like to see it? That
doesn't take a lot of money.
That does take patience and
creativity and, and hustle and,
and character and all that stuff
that is really, really important.
But that to me is why I
think now more than ever
before the leveling of the playing field
around entrepreneurship, it's not level
and it's definitely not level,
but it's more level now
than it has been previously.
- You were talking about,
you know, the belief
that it's possible and
sharing the examples
of when we look at other people
and see they've had success,
Hey, maybe we can too.
How do we solve belief? You
know, like so many people
with great ideas, you help them every day
and there's, you know,
10 times that number
or more just kind of sitting on their idea
and never getting started
and never open up a Shopify
still convincing themselves
that it's, it's too hard and
someone like them can't do it.
How do we, how do we
shake the limiting belief
that we can't do it?
- Well, we all have different leavers.
I mean, you know, my lever,
and I think your lever is
quite similar, which is
that we can, we can, we
can tell their stories,
we can tell the stories of
entrepreneurs that are unlikely
to have succeeded, but have, despite that
we can tell stories of,
of our favorite brands,
where they come from.
You know, I, I wear a
black hoodie most days.
I talk a lot about Blue
Salt because I think Lindy
and what Lindsay Lindy did
with Blue Salt is incredible.
Soul Angel, I think what,
you know, Eli did, and, and,
and the whole blue, the whole
soul Angel story is amazing.
I'm wearing Bombas socks.
I think what Dave did with Bomb is ama.
So I, I, the way that
I think I can, I can do
that is through storytelling
and making sure the world knows about,
about these great stories.
But I think the other thing
is also we should, you know,
I never went, I never took
an entrepreneurship class in,
in college, and I went, I did a,
a economics degree in
undergrad and then law school
and business school, but there was no eco,
there was no entrepreneurship
class per se.
However, I was an
entrepreneur throughout all
of those years from
like 17 till, you know,
I graduated business school in 24, 23.
I was an entrepreneur
and I was an outlier.
I've now recently met up
with, you know, classmates
of mine that I went to law school with.
And I've, you know, now that
we're all kind of, you know,
more and more grown up now than
before, they'll sort of
admit to me that they,
they thought in law school,
I was completely distracted.
They, they didn't think I was
taking law school seriously.
And I explained to 'em, I
was like, no, no, I, I was,
but I wanted something
different out of law school than you did.
You wanted to get a job out of law school.
I was greedy about acquisition
of information, knowledge,
and resources and, and,
and skills in law school.
I felt that law school,
I was paying law school $15,000 a
year to get, to get my degree.
I thought in return for that,
I was greedy in terms of,
okay, I need $15,000 of value
and the degree that you promised
me is not worth anything
to me, so therefore I need to get value
through the skills I
acquire in this program.
And, and then between
classes, I was sending emails
and taking phone calls and
running my, my t-shirt business.
So I, I don't know how
we change that culture,
but it still feels like today,
I'm sure someone listening
to this is probably an undergrad
or in graduate school
somewhere in high school,
and they're an entrepreneur,
and their friends think they're silly and,
and they think they're
distracted like they did with me.
I think we need to
change that a little bit.
I think that entrepreneurship
is not necessarily something
that, I mean,
even the term entrepreneurship is probably
not overly helpful.
My wife is an amazing entrepreneur.
She's a psychotherapist.
She also had an ice cream business, but,
but she's an entrepreneur.
She would never call
herself an entrepreneur.
She would call herself
a small business owner.
There, there are things that
we can do that we sort of are,
are, are doing inadvertently,
that I think makes
entrepreneurship less accessible.
We need to just make it more
like, if you ha, you know,
Nike did this amazing thing.
Nike convinced the whole
world that if you have a body,
you're an athlete, we need
to do a similar thing,
which is like we as, as a
community of entrepreneurs
where if you have ambition
and you have someone to
share with the world,
you very mu you very much
might be an entrepreneur.
And I think if we do that,
you'll see more people
try their hand at it.
Let's go. And then that will
be a flywheel that will, like,
after that happens,
you'll simply have this,
this, this, this.
The flywheel will just be spinning
and you'll, you'll, you'll see
so many more interesting things.
And by the way, as like
consumers of these products,
everything's going to get better.
You're going to have more choice, more,
more interesting products to purchase.
You've got to have,
you know, so much like,
you're just going to
have more interesting,
interesting things in your life relative
to if there's no entrepreneurs
and we're all just wearing Amazon basics.
- What I love is, you know, as you go off
and add more value than you're taking
and you create success stories
in different communities,
people can learn from someone
like you in an interview like
this and get inspired,
but you're creating little
mini ambassadors all
around the world, not just for Shopify,
but for entrepreneurship
that yeah, maybe they can,
they maybe they can't connect
to me, they can't connect
to you, but they can
connect to their friend
who started a Shopify store
and now they quit their
job and doing it full time.
It's like, huh, maybe I can do it too.
Like you're creating this little system
of ambassadors out there in the world,
encouraging entrepreneurship, which I love
the whole small business
versus entrepreneur.
Do you think, do you think
small business as a term is,
is contributes to limited
internal thinking?
- I don't have a better version of that.
I'll just use my own personal
situation with my wife.
Lindsay just doesn't like
the term entrepreneur
because it's the term
that I used ad nauseum.
I'm always talking about entrepreneurship.
And she's like, no, no, that's you.
I'm like small business ice cream person.
And I, I, I, I think nomenclature,
I think naming things
really, really matter.
And so I think, you know,
Shopify started as a small business
and it is now, I think the second
or something like that, one
of the largest companies in the country.
At some point we probably,
I think we were the largest
company in the country last year
by market cap ahead of
the Royal Bank. Does
- That sound crazy?
- Like I, I never, by that
sounds totally crazy amazing,
bigger than it's, I mean, Royal Bank,
it's, it's an, it's an amazing thing.
I think now we're still the
second or third largest c you
know, company in, in,
in all of Canada, which,
which is an amazing thing
from an, from an entrepreneur perspective.
But I'd never, I, I never
felt limited by the fact
that Shopify was a small business
or I, we never referred
shop as a small business.
It was just Shopify was a vehicle
to achieve a goal, achieve a mission.
I think that's a much better
way to think about it.
So if I had to roll back, not that I need
to give Lindsay any advice,
nor would she take the advice
from me, but, but Lindsay
and I were walking when we
first had our, our first child,
Bailey, around our
community here in Ottawa,
and we wanted to go for an ice cream.
There wasn't an ice
cream. And Lindsay started
to take some notes and test that ice cream
and learn about ice cream
and learn about like the
air content in ice cream.
Basically ice cream quality
is, is effectively a derivative
of how much air is in the ice cream.
So like a lot of air
is like Baskin Robbins
and a little bit of air
is like Haagen does,
it's just quality of ice cream
changes based on how much air.
So she went like deep into it,
and then she set up Sunday school
and started selling ice
cream to the community.
You could articulate as a small business
or an entrepreneur, a venture,
but ultimately all she was
trying to do is solve a problem.
The problem was, our community
here, Beachwood, which is
where we live in Ottawa,
Beachwood, did not have ice cream shop.
She wanted Beachwood to
have an ice cream shop
because people she thought
would like ice cream.
She solved the problem. I
think we should go in if,
if we sort of, you know, think
about this is like solving
problems as opposed to
putting monikers or titles or,
or any type of branding on it,
I think it's a better thing
to do it, but honestly, I, I don't know if
that's necessarily what's
holding back an explosion.
Entrepreneurship. I think
what's holding back an explosion
of entrepreneur
entrepreneurship is we as a,
as a society generally
don't embrace failure
the way we probably should.
And I think it's even more
prevalent here in Canada.
I, you know, I was born in
Montreal, I live in Canada,
probably live in Canada
the rest of my life.
But I I, I grew up, you know,
I went to high school in,
in south Florida, and I think in, in, in,
I think Canada actually tends
to be even more risk averse
than, than most countries,
at least relative to the
US in terms of failure.
We tend to, you know, there's
that tall poppy syndrome complex
that gets brought up
fairly often, I think,
I think you can get around that,
but I think it's, it's certainly present,
which is also why I like doing
great shows like yours here,
where I can talk more about
Shopify, I can talk more about,
you know, my life and my ambitions
and where I think Shopify can go
and why I think everyone
in the world should be an
entrepreneur at some point, or at least
a lot more people should be entrepreneurs.
Because I think that those
of us that have had any type
of success, those of us, that, those of us
that have any platform
whatsoever, we have to use
that platform to, to change something.
And you know, I I've,
years ago I used to go like
to like Startup Fest store
and at a big Canadian tech conferences,
and I get asked, you know,
what would I, what would I do
to fix up with the Canadian tech world?
And I would often talk about
the fact that, you know,
I want to see less acquirers
and more acquirers.
And what I meant by that
was I don't, not necessarily
that I wanted to see an increase in m
and a activity, I don't like that's fine.
What I meant though is that I
often would get asked about a
company in Canada, you know, Hey, what,
what should we do if we
want to get acquired by Google?
And I always thought of, I always sort
of thought it'd be a fun thought
experiment to, to say back
to them, well, have you thought about
acquiring Google yourself?
Like you acquiring Google?
Was Google acquiring you?
And, and of course that
would like, you know,
it would break their brains and
be like, whatcha talking about?
It was like, well, like,
you should think that way.
Like there is a chance and,
and a way for you to be as big as that.
And Shopify was, our ambitions
were always really big.
The reason we we went
public in 2015 was we want
to be a hundred year independent,
very large scale company.
We thought that was the best
way for our, achieve our mission.
And to do that, the IPO
was a part of that journey.
And so not only did we go public,
but we were very vocal
about our o our IPO process,
why we were going public, why
we thought it was a good idea
to go public, so on
and so forth. I think that stuff matters.
- I love it, man. I, I'm, I'm
curious like how to do it.
I remember somebody asked me
if I had an unlimited budget
to get my YouTube channel
set up, what should I do?
It's like, okay, you got unlimited budget,
you should hire like these five people
and start your, start your
channel and start to grow.
And then I, I sat back later
that night, said, well,
he said unlimited budget.
Like he should buy YouTube,
not just hire five people
and start his channel.
Right, exactly. So right.
It's, and like, I it, but
we just don't live there.
We don't live in that like,
I'm going to buy YouTube kind of mindset.
Is there, like, how do you
keep that big thinking front
of mind as especially the
leader of this company
that we're going to go
and change the world?
Like how do you not just
fall back to the norm
and what everybody else is doing? Yeah,
- There's a couple hacks to it,
but I think they're all
sort of per, they're,
they're all based on your
own personality and, and,
and, and what works for you.
I have been really lucky
and fortunate to surround
myself with a group of people,
friends, mentors, advisors,
coaches, psychologists,
people in my life, my wife, my my kids
who inspire me to think
bigger about things.
And I think that that is really important.
You know, it, it's, it's,
it's cliche of course,
but you know, that the whole,
you become the PHI people
you spend most of your time
with, that's a real thing.
And the flip side of that is like,
energy vampires are also a real thing.
There are people that give you energy.
They're people that take away energy.
And so I've tried to be meticulous about
where I'm spending my time
with whom I'm spending my time
with, and do I leave those
opportunities, those engagements,
those dinners, those drinks,
coffees, whatever meetings,
feeling more energized and thinking bigger
or less energized and thinking smaller.
And it's gotten easier.
I, I, you know, I, I'm incredibly
fortunate and, and, and,
and I know how, how, how
lucky I am that I get
to have people in my life like Seth Godin,
who I can call at any time
and say, Hey, here's what
I'm feeling about this.
Am I looking at this?
Right? And he is like, well,
like Seth's brain is like
the biggest brain ever.
He is like, no, I think
bigger. Or I can call Toby
or I can call, you know,
any of the people I work
with at Shopify, I can be like,
Hey, like, here's what I'm,
and they're like, Nope, think bigger.
But it's also required that I cull and,
and remove certain people from my life
who make me feel smaller
and, and, and think smaller.
And that, that, that's a tough thing.
I mean, you know, there are
people that were in my life
for a long time who just, I just,
it couldn't be in my life anymore.
And it's not because I outgrew
them, it's just their version
of, of of their vision for their life
and their, the way they look at the
world's different than mine.
And it is on me
because I let them affect
me, but they did affect me.
And so I was honest
with myself and said, I,
you're living your life.
I'm living mine, but every
time I spend time with you, I,
my life gets adjusted just a little bit,
but it gets adjusted a little
bit in the wrong direction.
So therefore, every time we meet,
just the volume gets turned down.
I, I, I want to be, you know,
I want to be fully present.
I want to be ambitious. I want live this,
this life that I envision.
I I've, I've tried to envision
for myself for a long time.
Therefore I need people that
turn up the volume for me.
And that matters, I think more
than almost anything else.
I mean, you can read
great books and you can go
to great conferences and
listen to great podcasts,
but for me, the way that
I am able to continue
to think really big about the
things is to be incredibly
deliberate and disciplined about who
I'm spending my time with.
- Love it. Well, final question. Yeah.
I'm curious who your
entrepreneur heroes are.
Is it, is it your
grandfather who sold eggs?
Is it Steve Jobs selling sugar water?
Like who do you, who do you look to
as your heroes of all time?
- I mean, my grandparents and
my parents, you know, play,
have played a huge role in my
life in very different ways.
The person actually that I'm,
I'm, I'm the person right now
that I'm, I'm, I'm really impressed with
and I'm, I'm, I'm really
quite inspired by,
is a guy named John Hope Bryant
actually recently joined his
board from Operation Hope.
John is an African American
business businessman, a
business person from the us.
He lives in Atlanta. I think
a couple years ago he was like
awarded like Banker of the
Year, like just super, super,
you know, high performing,
huge, you know, big brain,
very ambitious, very successful.
But a couple years ago he
said, I don't want to be a banker anymore.
I actually want to go
and I want to help more.
I want to create more
black owned businesses.
And so he just said like,
I'm going to take everything I
learned as a banker with
all this great experience,
all this great success,
and I'm just going to shift it
over to something else.
And I'm going to take that learning
and be focused on
creating, in the case of,
of a collaboration I'm working
on with him Shopify and,
and I was working on with him, we,
we want to create 1 million
black owned businesses in the
next, I think eight years
through this program.
He wants to create financial literacy and,
and then not only create a curriculum
around ential literacy, but then
embed it into the school system.
But I think what he's doing,
and he doesn't get enough
credit for it, is, is nothing short of,
of mind-blowingly ambitious and inspiring.
And every time I meet with John,
I think bigger about the whole world.
- I love that. We'll,
we'll get some info on John
and we'll link that up in the
description below as well.
Yeah. Harley, man, thank you
for the time, the energy, the love.
You left me with a whole
bunch of aha moments
and breakthroughs and
everything you're doing
to support the entrepreneur
community is amazing.
But your heart and your
care in, when you're ready
to get your YouTube channel started
or get that podcast going,
- I, I'll just come on your show.
You're, you're, you're, you're,
you're kicking ass on
the, on the YouTube thing.
It's, I, I, I watch your videos.
I think you're doing an amazing job
and thank you for telling the stories of
so many entrepreneurs that
really matters. Appreciate
- You, man. Thank you for coming
- On.
Okay, see you. All right, thanks
- To see my recent one-on-one interview
with Gary Vaynerchuk.
Check the video right there next to me.
I think you'll love
it. Continue to believe
and I'll see you there.
- I'm talking about something
that the world thinks is a contradiction.
I don't understand why anybody
should ever verbally dress
down an employee in a meeting, ever.